[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and i said to fritzy i said reach out to
ramona shelburne because
she had a great relationship with kobe
and she had such wonderful stories last
year uh the espn nba insider senior
writer and uh
ramona joins us i know you're busy today
being pulled in a lot of directions
ramona thanks for joining us
um when do you think the public's
perception or view of kobe
changed where you almost felt like you
could hug him or he would hug you back
as opposed to that assassin who was on
the floor
yeah that's a good question you know i
really think it was um i think that the
real change was that the years he won
the mvp that only
that only year he won an mvp award which
was 2008.
um and i think you saw kobe kind of
morph
from this guy who was like the real lone
wolf i mean we just
got done talking about the anniversary
of his 81 point game right
and well that that year was amazing and
i remember
you know he was throwing up 50 point
games all the time in that
that year because they had nobody else
around him and all that
like that was the kobe you know the
that was the old cobia that was the one
who you know
just shot a million times and his
teammates kind of never really
understood him and didn't
really play within the structure of the
um of the team and you know that was
mostly the story line
and then obviously with colorado that
that was a real
um i mean that's still a real blemish on
his record right i mean it's still
something that we
we have to note and we have to sort of
reckon with
um but but by 2008 like i think
some time it passed he had he had uh he
had changed
and that knew especially when they got
pal gasol on the team
he was he really was reinvigorated as a
player and as a
um as a teammate right i mean he wasn't
a great teammate before that and i
thought
he won the mvp because he became a
better teammate and you saw that side of
him and
i recently had a conversation with pogba
dan and i you know
he they they hit it off immediately and
it was something he told me something i
never had heard before which is
unbelievable this happened but i guess
kobe and powell
were um in barcelona at the same time
in the summer of 2007 so this is the
year before remember this is the parking
lot video where kobe you know okay
starts cursing at his teammates and you
know wanting it wanting them to trade
andrew buying them from jason kidd you
remember that video
yes um it's the same summer as a parking
lot video
and the same summer as his trade demand
and they kobe and his family are on
vacation in barcelona
and literally pogba falls working out
the hotel gym
down below and they like bump into each
other and start talking and
talking about how great it would be to
play together pow needed to leave
memphis and
kobe needed to uh kobe was not happy in
la and they weren't winning and
it was like they were like it'd be great
to play together and that was like yeah
there's no way because
the only way they trade me to the lakers
is for kobe right like that you'd have
to have equal value and of course
jerry west the man you uh then you
mentioned was in memphis
and he was dealing with his old protege
mitch cupchak and they
found a way to get that deal done and it
was amazing it happened
and that year kobe to kobe and tao it
was like
instant kyle said he got traded he went
through his physicals
showed up at the hotel at 1 30 in the
morning kobe knocks on his door
and is like you ready to go like we were
going to win a championship
i was like hello nice to see you again
it's 1 30 in the morning
but that was him and like how you know
for all of the
trouble that you know the hard copy was
hard on how really hard and i mean
you know he called him a white swan and
i'm the black swan
right and you know matt barnes told me
because sometimes i had to go over to
powell after colby would yell at him and
put my arm around him i mean he was
brutal with how but you know what
belle thinks of him like his older
brother because they they
he pushed him he got so much good stuff
out of it he got the best out of powell
and i think that's how we really
remember
kobe is just a guy who got the best out
of himself
and wanted you to get the best out of
yourself too did you get to know him
more
after retirement or when he was still
playing yeah
i mean honestly dan like the last
the last five six years of his career is
when we really talked a lot i think
i would say like the the year we
probably talked the most was
the year right after phil jackson left i
mean we would that was when he was
trying you know after phil left it was
like kobe had to figure it out
do you know what i mean like before phil
was the coach
and you know kobe trusted him to put the
pieces in the right places and
i'm still retired and it was like mike
brown and mike had tony
and you know the steady stream of you
know the lakers going with big swings
remember they traded for dwight howard
and steve nash that year
so those were those years where he was
trying to squeeze
one last championship he wanted to catch
mike man and like
that was you know he he's sitting on
five can you imagine like you're sitting
on five
and it's within reach and you have
talent you have dwight who he had
misgivings about when they traded for
him but he was like
i'm gonna make this work you know and
and i think
i i it was weird he would call in i
would i'd be hosting radio in la
and he was always driving from orange
county so he was always listening to the
show
and uh he was just like text or email
right in the middle of the show
and i remember the one was like we were
talking about dwight howard and
and i think i was going i was saying
what i thought dwight needed to be and
and kobe was like dwight just needs to
be like bill russell he needs to be
play defense and rebound and just be
that guy for us that's all we need we
don't need him to score
like he was coaching him through the
media
live on air so he's texting you while
you're on the air yeah
yeah great yeah of course yeah and he
wants because he's hoping dwight's also
listening
to what i say and we'll change that
right i mean it was like so kobe
so great what do you think kobe would be
doing what do you think his
next man his next uh whatever
uh incarnation yeah
yeah you know that's the part that's so
sad for all of us
and and you know like i know this is a
day i'm trying to
i'm trying to stay celebration of his
life you know today because i think
that's what vanessa asked for and um
and i want to respect that as much as we
can right that's i mean she
has his wife and three kids are really
the people we should all be thinking
about today right um as well as all the
family members of the other seven
seven people aboard um and i think
what's so sad about dan is that like he
had it all mapped out man
i mean he had you know he had his
investment fund he had
granted his studios like you know his um
his longtime manager her name is molly
carter
she uh she's much more than a manager i
don't even know if i should call her
that she's
she came over from gatorade nike and
stuff and
she was running kobe ink with him and i
mean he she told me like they had
so many projects lined up for granity
you know granity studios that's that's
the way he does the
the comic books and the and the um the
children's stories and all these other
things i mean he had
all this stuff lined up and not just
like season one i mean season 10
season 11 i mean he's like the original
streaming service or something right
and and you know what you know what pow
told me about why kobe got so into these
to making books for children he goes you
know
my i want my kids to understand the
lessons that i learned along the way
but they don't really listen to me so i
have to figure out a way to tell stories
that appeal to kids
like so so that kids can hear them and
learn them
i mean it's so cool man like it's just
you know and and that's why he did it
and i think he would just be doing all
this
um i think he would be you know
everybody in the nba all the young
players they all want to go work out
with kobe i mean
you know i remember a time when
everybody wanted to work out with elijah
on right
okay go to go to hakeem he'll teach you
yeah i mean that's what it is now like
the workout with kobe was
go to kobe just work out with toby and
and i'll tell you what it was always
going to be is like he's going to put
you through this hellacious
workout you'll probably want to throw up
at the end but like
like every player wanted to go do it i
mean it was like a rite of passage
i think that's what kobe was doing he'd
just be you know
his dad was four daughters a husband of
vanessa you'd be doing his
children's books and coaching and i mean
gigi she would be
you know probably i think maybe starting
high school
god dang man you know we'd be talking
about her because she was
i mean i'll tell you what the wmba
players i know who
you know of course kobe got wnba players
to come train with his
ten-year-old daughter right
of course he did that yeah of course um
they all said she was really good like
she was i mean like she was going to be
like a wnba player she was going to be
one of them not just
like on the team like she's going to be
kobe in the wnba
and we'll be talking about her too i i
want to play something for you
and this was the last time that i had
kobe on it was uh
april of 2018. and uh
we started the conversation talking
about coaching
here's kobe and you never gave any
thought to being a coach
i coached my daughter's team that's it
that's that's the extent of it
my daughter's team are you good
um well i mean they're learning right i
mean that's that's the
that's the key right you want to learn
we do run the triangle off oh no
it is the craziest thing in the world
like we'll be sitting there right we'll
be sitting there and i say okay
okay um let's come down um let's run a
center opposite
um top passes denied let's go back
doorstep
and then dribble weave with the guard
coming out of the corner and they'll go
out there and just execute it
boom how great is that
i love it i mean look there are some
things dan and this is
like every time i hear i love i love
hearing interviews because you know
like sometimes you're interviewing
someone and sometimes they're and you're
asking them a question they actually
respond to it
and other times they're just gonna go
yeah they're just gonna say you know and
and that's how kobe was right like we'd
sit down or talk and it was
i mean i had a question i'm sure i had
tons of questions he just wasn't going
to talk about he
he controlled what his story was going
to be right like or he told you what his
story
you know his version of and he was such
a
great um like there was
there's kobe the van and then there was
this larger than life
for sona and i just think he was
unbelievable
at not only building that larger than
life persona but
really being that i mean my favorite
kobe story is when he taught himself to
play the piano
okay and it was uh he was going to make
this grand romantic gesture to vanessa
they had um the year they were separated
right and
he taught himself to play moonlight
sonata
because you know he'd studied it and all
everything that went into that piece and
but it was like he could have got
lessons you know like of course you
could get
lessons to teach you to play piano he's
like no
i had to i had to teach myself by ear so
he would just
learn that one song like he didn't learn
to play piano he just learned how to
play mumbai sonata
and i was like and i was thinking like
when you told me the story i was like
that's amazing and he did it and you
know remember those videos he
posted some videos of him practicing um
it would be like three in the morning he
was posting this he's on the road at
some hotel
you know i don't know where they had
pianos on the road but he he brought one
with him i mean he was
like and i was just like did you just
teach yourself to learn to play by ear
so that you could tell the story about
it later so that it would be part of
that
like larger than life persona
and we probably did i mean i mean
you know some like there's a part of me
that's just like it's i chuckle
okay because if you or i did it we would
just like i don't know if i could take
myself like i'd laugh at it right but
he really was that like he really was
this guy who just
did these amazing largest life things
just so he could prove that he could do
him and i think he walked as a sort of
um figure like that he knew full well
you know when i when i went and talked
to some of his high school buddies
they took you know he talked about that
as a high school kid like you know you
played the
jerry west interview he knew how he was
special that back then yeah
i think kobe always saw himself that way
like he was just larger than my figure
and
he wanted to you know change the world
even when he was his high school buddies
so they you know they used to drive
in the desert in the middle of the night
you know all these kind of stories right
and like that's what they would talk
about he talked about how he was going
to make a big impact on this world man i
mean
he did he certainly did we're talking
about him now i'll always talk about him
i think
mamba mentality has just become
something everybody knows what you mean
when you say that
and i think about it i think about him i
think about his advice all the time
don't you
yeah it's just yeah you know yeah so i
he you know it's sad for me to think
like how much he had left to do and how
much all those people on the plane
the helicopter had left to do but i also
i also
man he did a lot 41 years
i know you got a busy day and i i but i
i singled you out
uh when fritzy reached out i just said i
i wanted i wanted to hear from you
so i i do appreciate you joining us
ramona thank you very much
appreciate you dan that's ramona
shelburne espn nba insider
senior writer